from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between 7-11 and japan and the u.s this
is food wars
in japan our coffee is coming
medium and large
and extra large
if you're getting coffee why not grab a
chocolate donut
our 7-eleven drinks come in sizes of 200
milliliters 450 milliliters and 1 liter
and 1.5 liters i'm sorry i couldn't get
it
in the us we have big gulps self-service
fountain drink for sodas and they come
in these four sizes medium
large
extra large double extra lot
so i want to see how much the biggest
size cup i could get of the 711 is and
to do that i will need hang on
just past 40.
it's exactly 48 ounces that's hardly
double extra i'll round it up because of
this section here i'll round it up to
50. 711 also at one point
offered a size that was even bigger
called the team gulp which again
according to them was 128
fluid ounces for
your team
because who doesn't like to after a
softball game go to 7-eleven get a team
gulp and 10 straws you know just kick it
with the with the boys right come on
team yeah right that's for one person
don't be ridiculous
[Music]
here are many many many
7-eleven items you can get in the u.s
you can't get in japan and here are many
of the 7-eleven items exclusive to japan
japan puts the convenience in the
convenience store we call it konbini
which is the abbreviation of the
convenience store and it makes our life
a lot easier for example office workers
rely on stores like 7-eleven for food
and drink to keep them happy so that
they can be productive at work
and for students they tend to buy juices
and snacks and hot foods instant noodles
you know and when i was a kid i would
often eat like hot foods and instant
noodles with my friends
and with my ex-girlfriends
7-eleven memories
i studio
[Music]
and for families there's pretty much
every daily essentials they may need and
also you can pay your bills get ticket
preservations for music and sports 711
even has its own bank and atms
no matter where you go especially in big
cities like tokyo you can find more than
one company on every block yeah it's a
bit different here in the us i do
frequent 7-eleven and it's not bad but
the vibe is more kind of like get the
thing you need and go
the food is usually pretty hit or miss
usually missed in my experience
the hot food looks like it's been
sitting up for a while so i usually
don't get it since there are way too
many items exclusive to japan for us to
buy for one episode so i've curated some
of my favorites for you guys this is
still a ton of food so here we have
japanese onigiris this one is plum
tuna mayonnaise
shrimp and mayonnaise mentaiko which is
spicy cut raw i picked these onigiris
from the back because onigiri in the
back are fresh
of all time and let me show you how to
open this one just put this over
to
here
like this
so that you can have the dried you know
seaweed
a little bit sweet a little bit of sour
so here is our sushi
look at this huge salmon sushi
gorgeous
gorgeous sushi itadakimasu oh my god
this is so delicious
[Music]
we got this long
natto roll
personally i love naruto but even
japanese people
fifty percent of them
like it fifty percent of them don't like
it this is an acquired taste
i stood
so after this sticky and smelly natural
i've got sushi roll special package
so when it comes to this one it's called
oina disan it has rice inside and the
skin is like a sweet tough skin
[Music]
this is so good
so like my grandma always cooked this
for me and this makes me happy all the
time
and next to onionism
this like gorgeous sushi roll it's like
japanese version of california roll is
[Music]
one thousand percent better than
california
kampio maki
in english it's like dried
gourd roll italics
sushi roll the last one we have pickles
radish pickles it's quite yellow it
definitely has yellow number five
itadakimasu
i'm gonna give them
grammy albert
i'm standing ovation
uh the hot food is 711 in the u.s we got
a lot of options not as many as japan
i'm not quite sure what some of this
stuff is just by looking at it so let me
go down the list nachos they're the
self-service nachos so they have the
chips ready to go and then you just open
them up and add cheese and chili onto
them
oh no thank you over here these mini
tacos man it's like really
who knows my face
oh man they've been sitting for a while
so don't forget them we also have wings
crispy and
not so crispy i could bean burrito guy
over here in the roller taquito section
you can get a barbecue bacon
cheeseburger roller spicy garlic roller
regular taquito korean bbq taquito also
we have chicken sandwiches a black bean
burger glazed cheesy barbecue meatballs
also at our 7-elevens you get a
pepperoni pizza cheese or seven meats
and also for hot dogs we got an
exclusive hot picante dog
no one so here are our hot food sections
we've got steamed buns
it's got pork and bamboo shoots and this
is really standard like nikuma so next
size up we have
the doubled nikuma
and next one this little guy
what is this
sweet beans skimmed one and last steamed
bun is
pizza bun
you really are the pizza
[Music]
delicious so all these things like um
around 100 yen to 200 yen or so so
if you're broke you should definitely
try this
we've got
these ones
this one is called cut it
it's like deep fried
curry bread how about you i want to eat
this
i'm gonna eat this right now itadakimasu
holy moly um it's freaking delicious
and next one crockett it's basically got
potato and pork means
and last hot food we've got is corn dog
so this one right here it's pretty
japanese one it's got ketchup and a
mustard and you just squeeze this one
onto this one all right let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go
in japan we have these chicken options
first i'm gonna start with this one
karage bowl
so in japan when you make japanese fried
chicken you put some soy sauce on it so
it has soy sauce flavor and also garlic
flavor
so freaky
delicious so this karage boys got
one two
three
and four karages we have
fried chicken
spicy fried chicken chicken nuggets
hot sandwich the buffalo style chicken
slider the cheeseburger and the
bacon cheeseburger i mean you can even
tell which ones
right which one
huh
i'm assuming avi says burger's been
cooked
more on this in the ingredient section
uh 7-eleven in the u.s
anything probably here in southern
california has tacos and burritos get
yourself a chicken fajita taco
al pastor taco but this one's good and a
chorizo breakfast taco the spicy beef
bean and cheese burrito this ain't any
burrito baby it's the bomb
bombing out the toilet good god you're
getting this and you're microwaving it
there so if you can you're like walking
out to 7-eleven shopping on the bomb
like
better make it home in time because oh
man it's coming empanadas right
i'm gonna go ahead and put this in here
and i close the lid like it's a coffin
go away forever all right so here are my
favorite bentos let's take a look at
this one it's called nori bento this one
is pretty popular one in japan so it's
got crockett a deep fried fish cake
fried fish with tartar sauce kim piragul
like japanese traditional salad pickles
and as you can see right here it's got
spicy cotton ball
under this seaweed it's got rice
and fish flakes
i love this pencil like when i was a
student i think i would eat this every
single day so after my favorite one
this one look at this so this one is a
korean style beef bento
oh man smells so good
everything right here is
so amazing fantastic this is so
mushy soyo
and it comes with this sauce for this
tonkatsu look how thick it is so outside
from bentos we have soba
soba noodle
put this sauce first
put wasabi
and dry the seaweed
and then you put water onto soba noodle
it's getting moist
and don't forget to put green onions
right here itadakimasu so you could soak
a noodle in this box
roomy
i guarantee you can't stop eating this
because it's so delicious
sorry i still love noodles because
japanese people or asian people
do make noises when you eat noodles we
slurp
slurp
slurp right now
they got the meals over there in japan
we got meals too like this ready-made
ricotta romano parmesan cheese stuffed
ravioli topped with marinara sauce much
just stop stop doing this stop please
stop
oh then so then it's like japanese
traditional hot pot it's got a fish cake
fried tofu noodle thing this is made
from potato egg
radish in winter when you eat this
this warms you up from your heart
to your body and next
graten doria so obviously it's got meat
sauce and a lot of cheese under this
cheese it's got a lot of rice in there
it's like japanese western food we have
seven premium main dishes
naan and butter chicken curry and next
we have seven premium side dishes
mackerel grilled mackerel we also have
mackerel in miso
zaba miso is
smoked tongue in japan it's pretty
popular item especially when you go to
like japanese barbecue restaurant we
order the like beef tongue or pig tongue
so this one used to be like this
smells so good so fancy
[Music]
it's marvelous so after this sexy tongue
we have sexy
fish cake and look at this bar
it's a chicken bar so it's like a
chicken nugget before it's fried octopus
and wasabi this is just raw octopus kim
piragobo it's a sauteed bird dog
stewed hijiki seaweed and potato salad
so like when i go home my mom always
cooks like this one this one this one i
love you mom
i miss mom's cooking
and next we have premium gold main
dishes shrimp with chili sauce beef stew
hamburg steak
sandwiches 7-eleven egg salad peanut
butter and jelly turkey and cheddar
cheese on a kaiser roll so we have the
italian style
sub but then we also got
the italian job
turkey and ham with is that cheese in
the picture there we got the smoked
turkey and monterey jack cheese sandwich
and they separated the lettuce so you
had it like rightfully ready to eat so
it's still nice and crisp salads chicken
caesar salad we also have a pepperoni
pasta salad so here are my favorite
sandwiches it's got tuna right here and
the cheese and lettuce
and the rest of these are ham and egg
i thought this is normal but you don't
have this one
fruit sandwich
it's got a whole bunch of fruits it's
got peach pineapples and oranges um
whipped cream so it's like cake so here
is seven premium drip coffee so i'm
gonna make myself a cup of coffee
and it just sits on here
all right
it tastes like
so for breakfast sandwiches at 7-eleven
you can get yourself a
croissant with ham egg and cheese ooh an
english muffin with bacon egg and cheese
we also have english muffins with
sausage egg and cheese sausage biscuits
and sausage egg and cheese croissants
the 7-eleven signature brand also has
mini donuts chocolate cinnamon crunch
and of course powdered madeline's
7-eleven cookies right at the register
for a dollar you can get yourself some
macadamia nut cookies oatmeal raisin
sugar but there's also chocolate chip
cookie one uh baked goods you get
yourself some muffins there's a
blueberry muffin coffee cake crispy rice
treat bar now since they're rice crispy
because you know that's copyrighted
walnut fudge brownie bear claw danish
iced honey bun
cheese danish mixed berry danish glazed
honey bun look at these pre-packaged it
says flavored snack pie it's a weird way
of putting it
key lime banana cream i feel like they
used the same as the same edge photoshop
right there buddy boston cream apple
and the last one strawberry cheesecake
key lime
it's key limey oh yeah oatmeal that's
obviously maple syrup right there but
the first thing i did when i looked at
it i was like wait does it have brandy
in it who's the oatmeal you can put hot
water in here joe or hot milk
or
hot whiskey your boss won't notice the
difference
well at first
here we have japanese type of bread
stir-fried noodles and sauce bread we
call it yakisoba
now you might be thinking what that
is this
so it's like hot dog but
instead of sausage we got
stir-fried noodle inside
carb
carb
it makes you fat bread makes you fat so
kids love this noodle and bread
itadakimasu
this one reminds me of my childhood me
playing tags in the mountain and chasing
the girls
now a lot of girls are chasing me
this is a crab thread it's got two
crab shaped bread now the question is
does it taste like crab
it doesn't taste like crab tastes like
just bread
pink bread it's a cherry blossom
flavored called dink bread
this pink stuff is it's pretty sour
it tastes like cherry blossom and like
my first kiss
this is the
salty savory snack zone ah so much stuff
and i've hit the food wars wall hot and
spicy crackling curls the original and
the fried pork rinds chili lime
i'm not tasting anything pork related to
it a little pig guy there
a little pig again you're on the menu
buddy next seven selects has their own
veggie straws
this will be the trail mix and mix like
section we got these uh cheese pizza
flavored snack mix and stinky boy if you
have a bunch of these
yeah they got the spicy ranch flavor mix
and this last one just sesame sticks for
those of you who like to
get your trail mix or your chex mix and
then unmix them and organize them and
eat them like that 7-eleven it's got a
snack for you oh this is kind of a party
snack mix
this is what i would totally get yogurt
yogurt pretzels like with yogurt on
there like you're thinking oh yogurt
that's healthy right it's just it's the
same as icing now you're looking at this
going jack links beef jerky that's not a
7-eleven brand no it's not but as you
can see exclusive 7-eleven flavors see
this was like hey jack links guess what
we're about to push you out on the [ __ ]
on our shelf space so do a deal with us
you're gone completely jack winks who's
like no i got kids to pick please brown
sugar bourbon
original recipe original
hickory smoked bacon like snacking on
cheese and nothing else full house baby
this one is mozzarella cheese wrapped in
hard salami pepper jack stick gouda
cheese to go oh the big one the big
cheese the white cheddar this ain't your
grandma's cheese it's the big one
just two cheddar cheese
colby jack which is like camouflage
cheese
pretzels
mini twist non-yogurted pretzel nuggets
ooh gross this one's a peanut butter
inside of them pretzel sticks i feel
like there was a while there in the
early 90s when they were like chips are
bad for you eat pretzels instead these
are really salty too a serving size of
these is three i would get this assuming
gonna sit and eat this whole bag in one
sitting i'm not gonna do three at a time
the whole bag is 1160 milligrams 50 of
your sodium intake mini rice cakes
chips 7-eleven has a bunch of their own
potato chips including the original
fiery hot kettle chips which are way
better than regular chips again spicy
jalapeno smoked gouda ooh buddha
barbecue
salt and pepper ruffles rip-offs we got
cheddar and sour cream prime rib i'm
trying these and buffalo chicken dip
prime rib oh it smells terrible
oh my gosh oh so bad it's definitely
have this
i have more like ground beef instead of
one of these like fancy forks would be
like a the plastic spork that they have
at 7-eleven they're opening the bag with
the spork meat's pouring out of it on
the floor of a 7-eleven with a guy
mopping around it
nuts baby nuts the rise and shine fiber
blend of a trail mix whatever
antioxidants yeah rights
revive and thrive auntie another
antioxidant mix should have just should
just handle these out during coven what
it bounced back in a week cashew
halves you like your nuts halved oh yeah
you like like nuts hold booyah doesn't
matter if they're whole or not that
would that affect the flavor at all who
cares spicy ranch
pistachios
and of course jumbo flavored
wasabi and soy nuts nope wasabi will
never touch my lips again after that end
of that video so here are my favorites
instant noodles let's start ippudo ramen
man i love this so it's got some pockets
a dried
pork it's a miso for the ramen soup
dried veggies
and it's got noodles
[Music]
all right
and you gotta wait for three minutes so
while i'm waiting for this i'm gonna go
this one so it's called
so it basically is a yaksuba yesterday
it's like a japanese stir fried noodles
so you put some hot water
onto this line
all right so it's been three minutes put
the soup
into this bowl
mix it
slow song
[Music]
bravo
epidural has a lot of locations in japan
including tokyo but this taste this
flavor is totally the same as a
restaurant serving so
just get it at 7-eleven
i totally forget that oh
so i put some hot water but oh
i should have thrown the water away into
the toilet
noodles let's make yakisoba
the volume of these noodles
gets a lot bigger
okay so put yakisoba sauce
and flakes
and most importantly mayo
mayo beam
and mix it up
so this is yakisoba like usually it is
like at like summer festival
pretty good as always next we have
takomeshi
look at this it's got a green onions
and i believe this is taco
so
three minutes again
look at this final
noodle it says
ultra
spicy final you're gonna be crying
because of the spiciness it's too spicy
but i'm gonna try this
only for a shooting purpose this is for
you guys
oh man
i'm so scared
all right so i think it's time to eat
this one so i'm gonna
throw the water away in the toilet again
let's go to the toilet
and put yakisoba sauce
already
[Music]
the test itself is lighter than this one
i prefer this one
but
but
this is the kink ramen
alright so
finally let's make
the freaking spicy noodle i call it
[Music]
in case i'm dead
please find another japanese host
it was nice to meet you put inside her
cool
oh man look at this
it's not red it's blood how do i need
this
[Music]
this is for you guys
[Music]
i'm not joking i'm not joking please
find another japanese
[Music]
a heart
ah
am i alive
am i not dead
i'm in heaven
hell
i feel like i'm in hell
it's not all junk food at the 7-eleven
joe and yuli they also have delicious
freshly sliced fruits pre-packaged and
everything came straight from the ground
and it comes in a container that will be
here
until the sun explodes this i mean this
has to be an la thing you can get mango
with tahini seasoning fantastic
combination finally grape cup 7-eleven
also has his own brand of packaged
candies
sour gummy bears
sour neon gummy worms sour watermelon
wedges green apple rings
gummy worms for catching gummy fish
i like that fruit leather whatever we
call this chili mango hello i'm trying
these sweetened mango and a sweetened
fruit medley
not bad ah a little spicier than i
thought
also gummy bears and gummy sharks it's
also gummy peach rings they got jelly
beans and they got sour cherries
7-eleven selects in the us also has
their own
line of
sandwich cookies vanilla
pumpkin spice
double chocolate peppermint s'mores the
duplexes lemon cream
so here are japanese sweets pink rice
cake with red bean paste
so basically uh it's like curry blossom
mochi
i want to eat this under the tree of
cherry blossom
cherry blossom
gochi
next we have
ninja gummy he's like ninja salary man
so it's a hard gummy
it's really tough
like stones
it's like pocky but like that chocolate
is inside
i'm loving it look at this cute guy
koala no
march chocolate
my favorite will be this one
when i was a kid i would eat this every
single day and this taste is so
nostalgic
little george is calling me like hey i
need this i want it hey
we are filming right now later after
shooting okay
okay okay
we're good
pretty
please prepare the plate and you just do
like this
one two three
go
this shape is like cherry blossom look
how jelly it is
[Music]
this is the best pudding ever we had to
go on a run to get more stuff that's why
visually this all doesn't connect stuff
mom's got macaroons french macaroons
mini cheesecakes
new york style and strawberry swirl
these i can get behind our 7-eleven in
the us has ice cream such as banana
cream pie caramel butter pecan chocolate
covered strawberry double cookie dough
cookies and cream sea salt caramel
strawberry banana shortcake so let's
start with cold stuff we've got fried
dumplings
it's frozen frozen takoyaki
frozen fried rice
so after these frozen meals
i got ice cream choco monaka jambo so
choco manaka jambo is like japanese ice
cream sandwich inside
let me buy it
sorry it looks gross
so it's got ice cream and it's got
chocolate in the middle and uh this
crunchy on the outside every japanese
people get this one at least once in
their life and last ice cream i got this
one gorilla chocolate ice cream
i don't know what this is
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry
this is delicious
not only me but
gorilla would love this a lot of
exclusive drinks uh i don't know where
to begin so i kind of lined them up by
perception of healthiness
so all the way down on this end we've
got 7-eleven select go smart cold
organic pressed juices
this one's the tropical glow and this
gross looking one is of course clean and
green
after that we've got these pre-packaged
juices these are the seven select
farmer's grove cranberry cocktail
raspberry lemonade orange juice of
course regular lemonade then next up in
the bigger ones we have the 711
teas peach black tea
sweet tea they weren't kidding man look
at that
lemon sweet tea and
green tea fruit punch mango
guava energy
come on
herbal tonic herbal dessertable guys
yeah 7-eleven also has their own brand
of are these energy drinks the gatorades
and powerades and the like replenish and
of course replenish zero i'm assuming
zero added sugar orange mango fruit
punch lemonade the cherry is clear
what why is cherry clear guava splash
orange mango these are bad 7-eleven
energy
strawberry lemonade energy shot one and
a half times with caffeine of a cup of
coffee oh good god
undrinkable how bad is that the taste
where this is too i can get through this
you've seen the show right you'll see
what i'll tolerate this i can barely
tolerate this
here's something that they don't have
in japan they don't have slurpees that's
nuts right slurpees are how do you
describe a slurpee it's like a flavored
slush
uh we have endless slurpee flavors the
ones currently you can get here in
america are blue rocketberry blood
orange vitamin water xxx blue raspberry
blueberry lemonade bliss cherry
coca-cola mountain dew citrus peach
perfect pina colada and pineapple whip
so here are japanese exclusive drinks we
have vegetable juice of course
we see a lot of japanese celery men
drink this one every morning to get
their day started so this one is for joe
joe
you're missing a lot of veggies so you
should drink this one
my favorite green tea
and these two are hot drinks black
coffee and coffee latte
and this is our first time filming this
we have alcohol we have seven premium
beer
and this one is not beer it's like
sprite with alcohol
it contains nine percent of alcohol it's
pretty delicious but at the same time
it's pretty dangerous japanese sake
when you come to japan you can see a lot
of people drinking alcohol outside they
were like
they're not dead they're just living
they're drunk
whiskey
7-eleven in the u.s has his own private
brand wines yosemite road trojan horse
plot and point and voyager point it also
has its own canned wine brand called
roamer perhaps the reason 711 has such a
wide variety of products in japan is
that it's everywhere in japan there are
21 215 stores in japan that's crazy
which is nearly 30 percent of all the
7-elevens in the world of course all 37
prefectures have a 7-eleven and out of
all of them the city of tokyo has the
most locations with 2 850. to put that
in perspective the u.s has 9417-7111
and there's no 7-elevens in 18 states as
far as states california has the most 1
823
but as far as
denseness in area
las vegas nevada has the most with
and fifty eight
[Music]
in japan our hot dog is 290 calories and
720 milligrams of sodium which is 31.3
percent of your daily allowance
our hot dog is 180 calories oh
how about this our hot dog is 180
calories but for the frank only the
stats for some reason don't say anything
about the bun but this isn't much better
for you it's 570 milligrams of sodium so
around 24.8 percent of your daily
allowance
japan's hand rolled tuna and mayo
onigiri has 258 calories and it's very
filling remember this guy the tuna
sandwich here in the u.s ours is 420
calories and lots of sodium over 800
milligrams
and in the us a super big gulp of
coca-cola this is in coca-cola it's 44
fluid ounces it's 513 calories and 143
grams of carbs it's over half your daily
intake
[Music]
in japan 7-eleven does not disclose the
ingredients list of especially mad food
items
it does however tell us the country of
origin for the raw materials for certain
items like the fried food yakitori oden
and chinese steamed buns
the chicken for our fried chicken is
from thailand the pork for our sausages
and hotdogs comes from usa canada and
japan the wheat for the buns comes from
canada the usa and japan and asking
beans come from canada cheese comes from
new zealand and the shrimp for the
shrimp chili buns is from vietnam this
is the pepperoni the pizza in the u.s
and it contains all this junk
i mean
what's this thing
never heard of that
what about chicken strips it's got all
this stuff
just like mom used to make and of course
the 7-eleven select cheeseburger which
contains
sesame seed bun has enriched flour
excuse me enriched wheat flour wheat
flour nice and sober taste iron monocero
today
serotonin
they're sitting down that's how long
this is going my camera person just sat
down
a preservative paprika and a nettle
color so i guess the last takeaway from
this video is that in the u.s some of
our 7-eleven items can be a little bit
of a gamble with your health speaking of
gambling you know your boy got some
scratchers when he was over at 7-eleven
okay so there's the winning numbers okay
so we don't win anything on that one
i have no clue how to do this
did i win
if you haven't subscribed yet subscribe
now
because we are filming this for six
hours
hey guys joe from food wars just wanted
to pop in and let you know that we are
officially starting a new food wars
season with a new country that's right
coming soon to the food wars cinematic
universe is food wars usa versus
india you may know him from his netflix
india show menu please please welcome to
the food wars family nikhil what's up
guys my name is nikhil kinney and i'm so
excited to be joining the food wars
hosting team india a land filled with a
million flavors delicious cuisines and
here i am to talk about kfc mcdonald's
burger king starbucks and many more it's
going to be a blast professional fast
food taster baby let's get it that's
right food wars usa versus india coming
to you real soon right here on food
insider so be sure to subscribe so you
never miss an episode